I wanted for them to learn to be
challenged in life and not just kind of
coached through I wanted them to strive
for more Kendra Espinosa was able to
send her kids to a private religious
school in Montana thanks to a state
scholarship program started in 2015
which supplemented the extra income she
was making as a bookkeeper and janitor
three years later the Montana Supreme
Court ruled that the program violated
the state constitutions prohibition on
public funding for sectarian or
religious schools now the Federal
Supreme Court will hear Espinoza's case
and how the justices rule will determine
the fate of Espinoza's daughters and
thousands of other children back in 2002
the court ruled that the US Constitution
allowed religious schools to participate
in government scholarship programs now
Espinoza and her lawyers from the
libertarian law firm the Institute for
justice are asking the court to go one
step further and prohibit state
scholarship programs from excluding
religious schools like the one her
children attend i sat down with Espinoza
on the eve of her hearing to talk about
the case what school choice is meant for
her family and what it's like to see
your name on the Supreme Court docket I
can do thank you for joining me thank
you for having us
so we are here in Washington DC you are
about to go to the Supreme Court to have
your case on school choice and religious
discrimination heard yes how does it
feel to have your name on a Supreme
Court case because that strikes me is
probably the hardest way to get into a
history book short of winning the
presidency it's humbling certainly had
no idea when this case started that this
would ever happen
had no ID No way of knowing that we
would be at the US Supreme Court but to
know that our name will forever be on a
court case of the US Supreme Court
that's pretty humbling for sure tell me
the story of how you got here today
it started with your girls who wanted to
go to the school of their choice
yes so the girls had originally been I
had homeschooled my girls prior to them
being in public school and it was a good
fit but life changed and I had to go to
work and so then I had to put the girls
in school so they were at public school
for a couple of years and they didn't do
terribly but they didn't do well and
there were struggles there with
students there were struggles with what
they were learning and I just didn't
feel like they were challenged enough I
didn't feel like they were going to have
as much opportunity as I wanted for them
to have and they weren't being taught
the way that I would have taught them at
home as far as their values they were
seeing things that I didn't want them to
be seeing so I started looking at other
options and found Stillwater Christian
school was really hopeful that I could
put them there but of course my mind
went to Wow how can this possibly happen
there's no way I can afford this and it
just took some creativity and made it
happen and now they've been there for
five years
so talk for me a little bit about the
fact that I think when people think
about school choice and you know even
when you think about the kind of
challenges that parents face sometimes
you imagine a more dramatic situation
you think of a kid who's in a very
unsafe public school or a kid who's
being you know violently bullied and I'm
sort of interested in your case and the
fact that you're the person who's going
to end up bringing this to the court
because for you it was just more about a
bad fit but I think a lot of parents
identify with that you really do want
the school that's right for your kids
can you talk about what it was that was
the real distinction between the public
school in Stillwater for you sure
because I I raised my girls in a
Christian home and because we had that
background of home schooling that
Christian education was foundational to
me I really wanted them to be taught the
same way that I taught them at home I
wanted those values to be the same I
wanted them to see things that we would
see at home and and certainly there's
going to be challenges that at a private
school to some degree that there might
be at a public school but I don't think
to the same level and I just found that
it was the school that the kids at the
school were different than the kids at
the at the private school there's much
more of a family atmosphere at the
private school but the academics are so
much farther ahead than at the public
school and I just felt like they were
not challenged enough and I wanted more
for them I wanted more opportunities for
them as they grow up I wanted the
to learn to grow up to be responsible
citizens and contribute to their
community around them but to learn to be
challenged in life and not just kind of
coast through on things I wanted them to
strive for more so you mentioned that
you were worried about being able to
afford the school of your choice walk me
through how the scholarship program
worked in in Montana for you but also
what other things you looked at in order
to to afford the school that you wanted
yeah the the school has a financial
assistance program as well and then
there are the there's a couple of other
scholarship programs so there's the Big
Sky scholarships and then a scholarships
and there's an application obviously
process for both of those and for their
financial assistance at the school I was
working my regular full time job and
then I've been working always always had
a second job at some points I've had
three jobs so I would do my regular job
in the daytime and then either
bookkeeping or office work from home
which is what I'm doing right now or
janitorial commercial janitorial in the
evenings and on weekends as well
the girls would come and help me with
the janitorial work because that was an
opportunity for them to learn good work
skills and work ethic and learn how to
put effort into something that they want
and so they wanted to continue to stay
at the school it was important to them
and so they were willing to come and
help me work during janitorial work on
the evenings and weekends and how did
the scholarship programs work are those
funded by the state they are not funded
by the state so the programs that the
donors are private donors contributing
to a private organization and the donors
will get a measly tax credit at the end
of the year so if they were to
contribute five hundred dollars to the
scholarship organization they would get
a tax credit of up to one hundred and
fifty dollars but they it's not state
money it is private donations to a
private organization who then looks at
the applications and decides who is
eligible to receive and then how much
they would be eligible to receive who
else is in the scholarship pool with you
and your girls do you have a sense of
the other families are they all going to
religious schools there's only one
non-religious
in our Valley where we live as far as
Montana goes I believe that the majority
of the private schools are religious
schools I don't know what the stats are
as far as how many there are but I know
that there's only one other one in our
Valley and that's not somewhere that I
wanted my girls to go the other families
they are probably medium to low income
families I know that all of them are
willing to work hard and they all
contribute as still a significant amount
to their children's tuition every year
just like we do but that funding that
extra bit of tuition and assistance
really does help our family to be able
to continue to stay there but for people
in your area and maybe really in your
state school choice necessarily means
looking at schools with the religious
affiliation there just aren't that many
correct secular private alguns
so talk about one of the keywords in
this case is discrimination and I think
it's actually a sort of difficult thing
to be to be asked to step forward and
say we're being discriminated against
that there's a long history of court
cases where or the Supreme Court or
other courts have attempted to sort out
the question of what discrimination is
and what it really looks like did you
experience discrimination would you say
that that's a correct way to describe
what your family has gone through
absolutely I believe that because the
Montana Supreme Court struck down the
entire program to ensure that no
students of religious affiliation were
to receive these scholarships it felt
like discrimination because the whole
intent of them they're the whole reason
that they shut down the program in the
first place was to make sure that nobody
of religious background got a
scholarship would you say that your
family is is typical of your
neighborhood of your community you know
is there is there a way in which you are
you're different than the public school
population I guess I'm just interested
in when we think about school choice we
think about the different needs of
different families how how did you know
that the public schools weren't right
for you and and you know what what sort
of sets your family apart from others
that led you to make that choice don't
think it was much more than the fact
that we have a faith I wanted to face
faith-based education I wanted
that same I wanted the same element of
faith and being able to be able now to
pray and being able to read the Bible
and study the Bible that was important
to me and I think a lot of the public
school there may be other Christians
there at the public school but that's
not how they're taught and they didn't
they're not taught to the children
aren't taught to develop their character
from a values perspective there may be
taught rote memory and they're taught
some basic academics but they're not
taught from a values based perspective
at all
how do you think what you're asking for
the courts to to do squares with the
values of the separation of church and
state I don't think there is an issue
there I believe that because these funds
are donated privately by private
citizens I don't believe that they know
the funds don't come from the government
at all in any way I don't believe that a
tax credit would be constituted as
public funds because the money hasn't
essentially ever gone to there or come
from the government even as someone who
follows school choice issues I actually
found that to be a really surprising and
interesting aspect in this case I think
many people would imagine that what you
and other parents are asking for is for
taxpayer money to pay for private school
that's not the case here it's not the
case actually in many school choice
programs there have been other states
who have set up similar models where
there's a tax credit or some kind of
incentive for private charitable giving
do you think people should be allowed to
give their money as they want or should
there be restrictions on how people can
give charity in general we are a free
country we should be allowed to give to
whomever we choose to give to and if
there's a program available for a tax
credit absolutely access that and the
fund those receiving the scholarship
funds should be able to use them where
they choose to use them what are you
anticipating for next year for your
girls school the same thing and every
year it's that same question can we
afford this can we keep going we will
continue to work hard and make the extra
income that we need but I just I
anticipate if this if we win on this
case and the funds are there for the
program to continue then we should be
able to make it as we have been all this
time cost of tuition will go up next
year because Naomi will be in high
school so the cost will increase at that
point so again we have to look at that
and look at our budget and say how much
can we what can we put aside what can we
extra can we bring in or how can we
bring in extra income and you've had a
lot of uncertainty over the last several
years between the case and just your
your family's kind of changes in
individual choices how does an
uncertainty play out for your family how
does that determine you know how you
think about your future I have never
been one to panic I suppose take each
day as it comes a lot of prayer and just
looking at the budget and I keep a
pretty pretty tight budget and I watch
that often and if it's something that we
really want I'm willing to work for it
whatever that takes we're willing to
work hard to make that happen there
comes a point where we can only work so
many extra hours and so then we really
rely on programs such as the scholarship
program if that's not available and
other programs aren't available then we
have to look at and consider going back
to public school which wouldn't be
necessarily a good fit for us do you
think there are other kinds of schools
or other types of education that
shouldn't be eligible for this type of
tax credit no I think that if the
program is available to the general
public I think it should be available to
anybody that accesses it regardless of
what school they go to would you say
that you expected to wind up where you
are now with your family when you
started looking at school options for
your girls no absolutely I didn't I had
no idea we would end up here in fact I
had no idea that we would even be
involved in any sort of a case like this
and we were approached by the Institute
for justice to partner with them and
become a part of this case with them and
my intent was yes I would be glad to
help out because this makes a difference
for other people not just for our family
and at the
time I wasn't a US citizen I was a
Canadian citizen still but I had legal
permanent residency and I had for up to
like 14 years up to that point but I
thought well I can't vote in a federal
election so here's my opportunity to do
something for the community have no way
of knowing that we would take it to this
level and that we would be here today so
it's a really it's a big surprise for us
thank you so much for coming in to talk
with us I really appreciate it Kendra
thank you
[Music]